this is a piece of world trade center
steel i take out and i share with
children and it's something that means a
lot to me and it means a lot to them it
was the same steel that pinned will
hermeno a former port authority
policeman to the ground for more than 13
the south tower collapsed as his team
entered the building to rescue others
himeno and sergeant john mclaughlin were
the only people to be pulled alive from
underneath the rubble of the twin towers
oh without a doubt it was a miracle
there was many miracles that day it was
a miracle of having a great leader like
sergeant mclaughlin who actually told us
where to run when the building's coming
out actually saw a debris field coming
toward us it's a miracle that
i was able to
push forward when i wanted to die
and it was a miracle that our bodies
were able to sustain such
trauma and now 53 he still wears a brace
the result of catastrophic injuries to
the left side of his body the battle
with ptsd is also lifelong
a former u.s navy veteran he agrees with
the decision to end the war in
afghanistan but not the way it was
enacted it was time to end the end the
war
i particularly am not happy the way it
was done
you know we lost 13 fellow americans and
there's a lot of good people in
afghanistan that you know i pray for
them because uh you know i'm a father of
two daughters
it breaks my heart to have to hear that
women are not going to be treated the
same that's that's very difficult
for the children of 9 11 victims
reminders of that day and not just on
anniversaries
john eagan's aunt christine and dad
michael were two of 67 britons who died
that day
the ache of loss has intensified with
the birth of his own son
every time you think you've you're okay
and you know enough time has passed to
to heal you know you cross a milestone
in life or
something happens um you know to me that
makes me think about my father more and
makes me wish i could have a chat with
him just miss him
do you feel like justice has been served
i don't think justice can ever be served
i i love many of the navy seals i've met
they caught us some of bin laden that
makes me that made me very happy to to
to know that to to hear their stories of
doing that that doesn't bring my father
back
it is just another day without their
loved ones each one equally painful
martha kellner sky news new york